boo like cat podcast man we got a
special guest here representing
Victorville she's I can't believe we
said that twice in two weeks shout out
to Victorville man let's get it man I
appreciate the opportunity to pull up
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
Victorville this year this year [__]
we've seen bodies hang off telephone
wires and [__] just walking down the
street Jesus Christ somebody must have
done some [__] ain't my business keep it
pushing oh my God this is uh El Dorado
yeah what's up everybody nice to tap in
thank you again for having me here of
course man appreciate it all right man
look man put on for the bill sheesh
shout out to the high desert man let's
go come on
hey yeah
where I stay I came from Rubble blessing
plays like NFL I've been cutting Paper
Trails nowhere Crossing nowhere hurt me
love my brothers did me dirty remember
days my mom was worried I've been
stressing overthinking what's the lesson
let it sinking in this tree gonna plow
my judgment imma chip his ass in public
high kicks to Johnny Cage for yoski in
that cage bro got 60 Standing Tall damn
my life amazed you might just turn a
page in the book pushing plays in the
book had a real em on the hook yeah I'm
pushing this line Homie don't trip yeah
my pockets will skip [__] I was talking
to God and I was late on the rent I know
I'm flawed 180 hit that spin and it paid
me my sins all it's a cold 100 packs on
the road when they get hot it gets Shady
couple months in this gravy stop moving
that Katie sipping [__] with some chin
yeah this policy code [__] to Polish I'm
cold yeah this quality clear I'll be
talking to myself and apparitions appear
I be talking to myself sometimes I look
in the mirror yeah she Gomez ain't no
dude stay fed told them one day baby
I'll be on bootleg cam with the robbers
interference locked in in his family I'm
an inland baby homie if we locked and we
family bro strutting the Animus bro
puffing the cannabis I came up out the
frame my soul studded in amethyst yeah
and it's that fresh scoop of CMOS damn
glowing through the Merc tell them what
it is I just tell it how it worked been
chasing hella backs man high as a
helipad sipping malice in my challenge
damn it they drinking slow system packs
out to Dallas got some plugs I ain't
seen before always moving work that's
just really how it goes and always send
my flowers homie really before they go
damn oh scary homie El Dorado hey what's
your IG man so what can I call you can
find me on El Dorado
e-l-d-a-h-r-a-d-o you feel me are
bearing the family FG Camp I.E [__]
let's get it fool
that was fire brother you nailed that
[__] thank you hey I know you just
watched the new freestyle guess what
we're dropping them every week sometimes
more than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off in check out you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week